so we had a lot of plans we were going
to go to Greece in uh in the summer
we're having to move that up because
we're having a baby
[Music]
Maria Menounos breaks down in tears
revealing she's having her first baby
you guys have been on the journey and
I'm so grateful oh my God that's so
great for you how are you feeling how
are you doing I mean
on Tuesday Maria shared the happy news
that she and her hubby Kevin undergaro
are expecting a little bundle of joy via
surrogate during a stop by Live with
Kelly and Ryan you've been trying a long
time almost like a decade guys it's been
a long time we've done everything I mean
literally everything they've tried to
you know get me pregnant that didn't
work Kevin had a surgery that didn't
work he's hung me upside down like a
chicken that didn't work over the years
Maria has opened up to ET about her
journey to Motherhood the see a timeline
is there like something you have in your
in your mind soon soon yeah oh my
goodness yeah Kevin actually texted me
yesterday he's like that's it I'm ready
you know it'd be really nice if there
was one in here right now back in 2018
shortly after she and Kevin tied the
knot Maria told E.T they were ready to
expand to their family but they had to
consider their options after Maria had a
benign brain tumor removed the year
prior we're ready to figure it out
um the only
weird thing is that I froze embryos and
I now can't implant them because if I
implant them and do all the hormones the
tumor will grow
so there's one way around it that we're
investigating right now and then
otherwise a surrogate but by 2019 Maria
told E.T they were moving forward with
the surrogacy process
today Kevin finally sent in our
paperwork
to the surrogate agency because it's
been sitting on my desk for like two
weeks like let's go have these kids and
so yeah we're moving forward you never
know maybe by next Christmas we'll have
a little Marie and Kevin's running
around well it looks like their dream is
coming true and Maria says they are so
grateful our surrogate and her family
are literal Angels I'm so grateful that
we're going to have this extended family
that our baby will be part of and um and
we're just so grateful to everybody
who's helped us along the way
foreign
[Music]